MAYANK TAHILRAMANI:
Hey, everyone.
Thanks for tuning in.
Really appreciate
you joining us today.
Today we'll be
talking about GitOps
in the context of GitLab and
Anthos Config Management.
So really looking to talk
about more detail on how
organizations can adopt GitOps,
the cultural aspect of it,
with the right technology
toolsets, GitLab and Anthos.
My name is Mayank Tahilramani.
I'm a senior alliance
manager here at GitLab.
And I've had privilege to
work with many different teams
across Google to bring to
market how GitLab and Anthos are
lowering the barrier
of entry into DevOps
and cloud native best
practices for our customers.
I'll pass it to Theo
to do a quick intro.
THEO CHAMLEY: Hi, everyone.
Super happy to be here.
I'm Theo Chamley.
I'm a [INAUDIBLE] solutions
architect for Google Cloud.
And I welcome [INAUDIBLE]
DevOps topics.
And I happen to be a
fairly heavy GitLab user.
Back to you, Mayank.
MAYANK TAHILRAMANI: Brilliant.
So before we dive into
the joint solution,
let's talk about
the core building
blocks of what we're discussing.
Give a little bit of
context and background.
Particularly around
the core building block
of Kubernetes as a robust
platform and service
to manage all your
container workloads.
As companies look to move
into microservice space
for architecture and
containerized or application,
Kubernetes becomes the de
facto platform to deploy to.
And as organizations grow
and complexity arises,
you can imagine more and
more Kubernetes clusters
across hybrid or
multicloud environments
become the de facto norm.
So to manage that
complexity, whether it's
across policy management,
networking, managing
different clusters, all of that
complexity can be addressed
with Anthos as a solution.
Anthos is a unified platform.
It's managed applicable
for multi and hybrid cloud
environments that are
running Kubernetes workloads.
Particularly with
Anthos Config Management
that we'll be focusing
on today's talk
on how you can manage those
policies and declarative
code to manage complexity
across your different clusters
and environments.
On top Anthos, it
is GitLab which
helps you provide that
workflow management
capability in a
single application
for your operators,
your developers,
for your security engineers.
A single pane of glass
where they can all
work, store their code,
and provide information
concurrently and collaboratively
as a single source of truth.
A single DevOps application
that can help you
manage how you
operate and deploy to
across Kubernetes
clusters using Anthos.
But that's the
technology aspect of it.
Let's also talk about the
cultural aspect of it.
Why even go down the route of
declarative infrastructure,
declarative code to
operate your complexity?
Why GitOps in general?
Really with GitOps, you
get a lot of reliability.
Once you've defined it and
fully automated the process,
you're able to replicate
it in a reliable fashion.
The more your software
defines your operation,
the more your software
defines your business,
the less human intervention
that you have to work with.
You abstract and
allow humans to focus
on the intellectual
contributions
to your iterations and
improvements versus having
error-prone processes,
where different teams
are having to communicate
with each other
to asynchronous or different
means that are not automated.
Accessibility becomes also
another great value proposition
of GitOps.
Once it's in Git,
it's versioned.
It's the source of truth.
You can track the change.
You can concurrently collaborate
as things are being ported,
changed, and redeployed.
You can track those
changes over time
using Git as the
fundamental protocol
and then using GitLab for
the workflow aspect of it.
At the end of the day, you're
using familiar tools when
you're trying to adopt GitOps.
You're using
Kubernetes manifest.
You're using YAML.
That's much more
declarative and explicit.
You're using CI/CD and
merge requests in GitLab.
And you're using Git,
allowing more user personas
in a single pane of glass
to operate familiar tools
that developers are already
familiar with today.
So let's now dive into the
reference architecture.
How do we configure GitLab
and your repositories
to work better,
to work seamlessly
with Anthos Config Management?
Theo, do you mind walking
us through this slide?
THEO CHAMLEY: Yeah, sure.
Thanks, Mayank.
So really, this is our
reference architecture.
On the right, you have two
Google Kubernetes staging, one
staging and one for production.
You, of course, can
have more than that,
but that's just our example.
And in the center,
here in that gray box,
we have the core of the
system, which is GitLab.
And we are using GitLab to
host three different Git
repositories.
And the first one that
I want to talk about
is the one in the middle
with the black logo.
It's called Anthos
Config Management.
And that's a Git
repository that's
going to be mainly used
by the platform teams.
And the goal of Anthos
Config Management
is to bring a GitOps approach
to configure the policies.
So with that repository,
when you commit a config
to that repository, you will
be able to automatically apply
that configuration or that
policy across all your clusters
at once.
Anthosd because it's
in a GitLab repository
and because it's declarative,
you can use all the usual Git
workflows and GitLab
workflows that you're
used to, such as merge
request, or approvals,
or CI tests, et cetera,
et cetera, et cetera.
And on the left, we have
two other Git repositories
that are used for the last
component of this reference
architecture.
This last component is
application delivery manager,
or appctrl for short, which
is the name of the CLI.
And so we had Anthos
Config Management.
That's GitOps for
config and policies.
And we have appctl.
That's GitOps for applications.
So the first of those
two Git repositories--
that's the one
with the red logo--
that's the application
repository.
And that's really a normal
application repository.
In our case, it's
called HelloWorld
because I'm a fairly
bad developer.
But it's really a
normal Git repository,
where you have your source
code, be it Java, Python, Ruby,
whatever you want.
The only difference is
that you have basically
templates for your
Kubernetes configurations
in that repository.
And in that repository, you
work as you would normally.
And the last repository is
the one with the yellow logo.
It's called
deployment repository.
And that one is mainly
managed by appctl.
You don't have to
interact with it too much.
And the only thing
that it contains
is the fully built
Kubernetes configurations
that are built from
the templates that
are in the first repository,
the application repository.
And so that last repository,
the deployment one,
contains those
full configurations
for each environment.
And appctl is going
to apply those as-is
to your different
Kubernetes clusters.
So let's deep dive into the
first of those components
that I mentioned, Anthos
Config Management.
So just to preface everything,
Anthos Config Management
is part of Anthos and is a
globally available product
today.
So it actually has three
different subcomponents.
The first of those is
called config sync.
And config sync is taking the
configurations and policies
and everything that you
have in your Git repository
and applying that to
your Kubernetes clusters.
And really, it can be
any common subjects.
But we are focusing on config
and policies and things
like [INAUDIBLE] or [INAUDIBLE]
or network policies,
those kinds of things.
The second of those components
is called policy controller.
And that's a managed version of
an open-source project called
Open Policy Agent Gatekeeper.
And policy controller allows
you to enforce policies
across all of your clusters.
So for example, if you
want all your deployments
to be labeled with
an Owner label,
allowing you to identify which
team owns which deployment,
then you can enforce that
with policy controller.
It was declared the policy
in your Git repository.
And every time
that the deployment
is going to be created,
policy controller
is going to allow
that creation on it
depending on what you
have in your deployment.
And the last component that
I'm not going to demo today
is called config connector.
And that makes the link between
Kubernetes custom resources
and GCP resources.
So for example, you can
have a Cloud SQL custom
resource in Kubernetes.
And the config
connector is going
to create and manage for you
the corresponding Cloud SQL
instance in GCP.
And between config sync
and config connector,
you can declare
your GCP resources
in your Git repository and
have them created and managed
in GCP.
So let's move to
the next component,
which is application
delivery, AKA appctl.
So appctl is not
yet a GA product.
It's prerelease.
It's freely available.
And we are actively looking for
user feedback on that product
to make it even better and even
more flexible for the users.
So as I mentioned
previously, appctl really
works with two repositories.
On the left here
with the red logo,
we have the
application repository.
And it's really a normal
application repository,
where you're going to develop.
You're going to create commits,
create branches, create merge
requests in GitLab,
and have a peer
review on that merge request,
[INAUDIBLE] CI test, et cetera,
et cetera.
And once that merge
request is approved,
you're going to merge it
back on the main bunch.
It's called master here.
And once you want to
release your application
to your various
environments, you're
going to tag a specific
commit-- in our case, 1.2.3.
At that stage, you can
handle the common appctl
prepare staging.
And what that does--
looks at your
application repository,
takes the last state of that,
and builds the full Kubernetes
configurations for that
version of your application.
And create a merge request
in the deployment repository
on the right here
with the yellow logo.
We have that full
Kubernetes configuration.
And because it's a merge
request, you can review it.
You can run a CI test in GitLab
here on that merge request,
all the normal things.
And really, it allows you
to see exactly what's going
to be deployed in staging.
And once you're fine
with that, you actually
merge that onto
the staging branch.
And you run appctl
apply staging.
And that's actually going
to deploy your application
in staging.
And you can see that
in that repository.
On the deployment
one on the right,
we have multiple branches.
And we have actually one
branch per environment-- one
for the staging environment,
one for the prod environment,
and one for other environments
if you have other environments.
And the last thing
that we want to do
is promote our application
from the staging environment
to the production environment.
And for that, we are going to
run the command appctl prepare
prod from-env staging.
And appctl is going
to look at the version
that you currently
have in staging,
build the full
Kubernetes configurations
for prod, but with the
version used in staging,
and create a match request
for the prod branch
that you're going to be
able to review, test,
et cetera, et cetera.
And once you merge
that merge request,
you can run appctl apply prod.
And that's going to
deploy your application
in production with
the same version
that you had in staging.
So I know that all of
that is a lot to take in.
So I think it's better
to look at a demo
and to see how everything
works together in reality.
We are starting with
two GKE clusters, one
for the production
environment and one
for the staging environment.
As you can see, I have
access to my staging cluster
in that case with three nodes.
This is the Anthos Config
Management Git repository.
And in this repository, I can
define the config policies.
In this particular
directory, for example,
I can list my clusters
and give them labels.
This is also where I'm going
to define my namespaces.
In our case, I'm defining
an HelloWorld namespace.
Just putting that
namespace in that file
makes it appear in my
cluster, as you can see here.
The HelloWorld namespace
already exists in my cluster.
In that repository,
I already have
merge request created
for this demo.
And this merge request
is going to allow
me to modify configurations
and policies on that cluster.
So for example here,
the merge request
is designed to add a
constraint to policy
that says that every deployment
in the namespace HelloWorld
and SEN tests need to
have a label called team.
And for that merge request,
because it's GitLab,
I can just have a
GitLab CI pipeline.
And here, I have
a couple of jobs
that [INAUDIBLE] that my
configuration [INAUDIBLE]
is valid.
And also that validates
that my own configuration
is compliant with the
policies that I set.
To change policies,
of course, you
want to make sure that everyone
who needs to approve a policy
change is going to approve it.
So in that case, we are using
the approval feature of GitLab
to make sure of that.
And in that case,
I just gave myself
the approval permissions.
So we are going to merge that.
And you're going to see that our
new policy is going to appear
in the cluster fairly quickly.
And here it is.
So until now, I was playing the
role of a platform [INAUDIBLE]..
Now let's switch.
And let's say that
I'm a developer.
I have this very simple
hello-world application
that just displays
"Hello, world"
potentially with
a custom message.
And it's written in Python.
And I have [INAUDIBLE]--
everything very normal.
And I have a CI pipeline
for that application.
And I'm going to use appctl
to deploy that application.
So I initialize my
project with appctl.
And it's actually
going to create
a new project, HelloWorld
deployment that's
going to contain my
configurations that we're
going to deploy to my clusters.
And in my project
now, you can see
that I have two new directories,
one called Delivery and one
called Config.
I'm now initializing my two
environments for appctl.
So I can start by adding
the staging environment
by specifying which
cluster and which
namespace I want to deploy
my staging application in.
And then I just do the same
thing for the prod environment.
Once this is done,
both environments
are going to show up in
the Delivery directory.
Here you can see just the
definition of the production
environment.
Now the Config directory is a
customized config directory.
And you can see that appctl
has provided the skeleton
for my environments.
To make things simpler, I'm
just going to copy an existing
configuration.
And you can see that now
I have a deployment, where
I don't specify the image
type tag and a service file,
where I create [INAUDIBLE].
And in the customization file
for my base configuration,
I am going to modify the
tag that I'm going to use.
I'm just going to use v.0.0.1.
And I'm referencing the
resources deployment
[INAUDIBLE].
And now for each environment,
I am modifying the message.
I'm giving a custom message.
Here you can see for
the staging environment,
I'm seeing "Hello,
[INAUDIBLE] world."
Now let's commit tag and push
everything to the GitLab.
And obviously, this is going
to trigger a CI pipeline.
That CI pipeline has
several stages, including
one with three different tests.
And if we looked at, for
example, the unit test
or in this case,
the linting, we are
going to see that GitLab
detects some problems
with [INAUDIBLE],, which we don't
care too much about right now.
And here, you can see the unit
tests that have all passed.
That is important.
But you can see that
there's a third test that
hasn't succeeded.
And that's the Validate stage.
And what does that stage do?
As you can see, we have
here policy validation,
the same one that
we saw earlier,
where it says that all
deployments must have a Team
label.
Where does that come from?
It actually comes from
the previous stage,
where we downloaded the
policies from the Anthos Config
Management repository.
And how do I do that?
If we take a look at
my GitLab CI YAML file,
you can see that I actually
include another GitLab CI YAML
file that comes from the
Anthos Config Management.
So the platform team has
provided me [INAUDIBLE]
with everything that I need to
check that my application is
compliant with their policies.
So let's fix the
policy variation
by adding this famous
Team label now.
Label Team, team
HelloWorld-- we don't
care too much about
getting value of the label.
And now let's just
update the tag.
And once again, commit
tag and push everything.
Of course, this creates a new
CI pipeline and [INAUDIBLE]..
This one is going
to actually succeed.
While we're waiting for
that pipeline to finish,
let's use appctl
to actually deploy
in the staging environment.
So here, I'm using the
appctl prepare command.
And I'm seeing that they want
to deploy the tag with 0.0.2
to the staging environment.
And what does that do?
It actually creates a merge
request on my over repository,
if you remember, the
HelloWorld deployment one.
So let's take a look
at that merge request.
Here, you can
notice that I am not
in the repository for my
application [INAUDIBLE]
HelloWorld deployment
repository.
That's the one that
contains the manifests
that I'm going to deploy.
And that merge request
is a merge request
to add the fully [INAUDIBLE]
manifest to this repository.
And as you can see, here in this
manifest, I have an image tag.
And I have my custom message.
And I have moved my deployment
and service in the same thing.
And you can see that
I am actually merging
into the staging branch.
So appctl uses one
branch per environment.
And the name of the
branch is the name
of the environment [INAUDIBLE].
So I just merged
that merge request.
And in parallel, the CI pipeline
on the HelloWorld repository
has finished.
And we actually
pushed the new image
to our container registry.
And now we just have
to use the appctl apply
staging command to actually
deploy our application
to the staging environment.
That command is
going to take what
exists in the staging branch
of the HelloWorld deployment
repository and is going to
apply it to our cluster.
So this is apply command
takes a little bit of time.
But once it's
finished, we actually
have a new application
in the Applications tab
of Google Kubernetes Engine.
Here you can see my
HelloWorld application
in the Staging cluster.
For now, it's empty.
But very soon, we
are going to see
the different components
as [INAUDIBLE] service
and deployment.
And you can see that we
have very specific version
of that application
that is [INAUDIBLE]..
And if we look at our
HelloWorld namespace,
you're going to see the
HelloWorld deployment and a job
that has deployed [INAUDIBLE].
And now, we can just look at
the HelloWorld service and at
[INAUDIBLE].
This is just a
little bit sped up
because we are waiting for
the [INAUDIBLE] to come in.
While waiting for the
[INAUDIBLE] to come in,
we are going to actually prepare
deployment to production.
And in that case, we are not
going to deploy from a tag.
But we're going to deploy
from the staging environment,
meaning that we're going to
promote a diversion that we
have in staging to the
production environment.
And it's just the from-env
parameter instead of from-tag.
And like before, it creates a
merge request in the HelloWorld
deployment repository,
in the one that contains
my [INAUDIBLE] configuration.
And in that case, we
are going to merge
onto the production branch,
the prod branch and not
the staging one.
And in my fully
[INAUDIBLE] manifest,
I'm indeed using the same
version of my application.
But now I have a
different custom message.
So it's merged.
And in the meantime,
the [INAUDIBLE]
probably has been created.
Yes.
Here, you can see it with
the staging custom message.
Now let's apply our newly
updated configuration
to the prod environment.
And that's exactly
the same process
as for the staging environment.
Appctl is going to take
the tip of the prod branch
in the HelloWorld deployment
repository and apply it.
And we're going to have a new
application in the applications
page of GKE.
And it's going to be exactly the
same thing as for the staging.
Here we have our
new application.
And let's take a
look at the service
for that new application.
It's, of course, in the
HelloWorld namespace,
in the prod cluster.
And let's refresh to get the
actual IP of the service.
And here, we have service with
the production custom message.
MAYANK TAHILRAMANI: Brilliant.
Theo, thanks for that demo.
Now that we've seen the
solution live and in the demo,
let's take a half step
back to really recap
some key takeaways.
Really answer that
question-- why
GitLab and Anthos for GitOps?
As mentioned earlier, Google
and GitLab partnering together
to really lower that
barrier of entry
into the GitOps
workflows, particularly
for those companies that are
standardizing on Kubernetes,
trying to manage their
complexity, trying to software
define their business to be
more iterative and agile.
As they explore
best practices, Git
becomes a fundamental
building block
to kind of provide
that audit trail,
provide that coherent
[? cohesity ?]
of the single source of truth.
Using GitLab as a single
application just beyond Git--
with the approval workflows
with merge requests,
automation pipeline-- you
got a single application
with the user interface
and user experience
for all the different
users and organization BUs
are invested in continually
improving the business
through software-defined means.
Why limit declared management
to app and only infrastructure?
Look into policy management
as well as Theo demonstrated
with Anthos Config Management.
Use the power of Git to manage
your configs and policies
while enforcing strong
security posture.
Really with GitLab
and Anthos, you
get a full developer
experiential, full DevOps
experience in a
unified platform.
You standardize on a single
DevOps tool and a single DevOps
application, on top of an
open and unified platform
that your company
can adopt quickly.
At this point, you're
probably wondering, well,
how do you get started?
Where to begin?
Great news is we are
partnering with SADA and Arctic
as channel partners
that can help guide you
through that process
and really help you
adopt what you saw here today.
Alternatively, we do
have reference material
that you can check out offline.
We've got two solution guides
that are readily available
today, where you can
see and read more
about the best practices on how
to architect that application
repository that
Theo was mentioning,
where you store
your config policies
for your multiple clusters.
This is a solution paper
that Theo actually wrote.
So definitely check it out to
get more finer detail on how
you build up that repository.
Additionally, we've got
another solution paper live now
that helps you and outlines how
you can deploy GitLab on prem
on a GKE on-prem cluster that
may be managed by Anthos.
So if you're looking
to get started
on a hybrid environment, that
might be a great solution paper
to check out.
Additionally, we've got
a lot of documentation
available as well on Anthos
Config Management in general
on Google's Docs page,
as well as finer details
on the appctl utility
on how to use it.
We've got documentation
on GitLab,
on best practices, on what
the GitLab flow looks like,
how to make most
of merge requests,
and how to architect
different repositories
and CI/CD pipelines
for your use case,
so you can be
flexible and nimble.
We do have supplementary
videos to this session, which
have a broader perspective
on how you can use
GitLab and Anthos in general.
So feel free to check
that out as well.
So with that being said,
I want to thank everyone
for tuning in.
Thank you for your time.
And hope you enjoyed
this session.
Hope to hear from you soon.
Cheers.